Thank You Adam Twitter has been
extremely busy tonight I'll give you
some of the figures for some of the
people sitting at home watching the
debates on their screens and and
tweeting simultaneously look it's
dropped down at the moment to five and a
half thousand tweets per minute at the
peak that was about 11,000 tweets per
minute that's the number of tweets who
are they talking about that's really
important well if you look at this graph
here they're talking at the moment about
the Tories and labor they're right up
there and look at this this is what's
really interesting their SNP Nicola
Sturgeon a strong showing right towards
the end people talking about her more
than they're talking about Nigel Farage
and UK and almost as much as they're
talking about the Lib Dems here is what
they're saying so you know about the
numbers of people who are tweeting this
is what they're actually saying let's
look at the positives first of all the
positives for Nicola Sturgeon a clear
winner tonight 23% of all the tweets
about her as almost fifty thousand
tweets twenty-three percent of the
people who tweet about her said she was
the most positive who was the least
positive David Cameron with only six
percent just marginally below Nigel
Faraj of UK Ed Miliband 12 percent there
48 percent in the neutrals they're all
about the same the 50s and the 40's for
the neutrality 'z but certainly Nicola
Sturgeon a very strong showing there
according to Twitter there were about a
million tweets sent out during that
debate oh that's a really big number
here you've got it just tailing off
there 1.6 million tweets over the last
24 hours a million tonight let's have a
look at some of the tweets that have
been sent out tonight
Jonathan friedlin Faraj is so Marmite
ETOPS calm raise his halftime poll of
who did best and who did worse let's
have a look at another one here's James
Kirk up from the Telegraph he says if
the big UK parties take one lesson from
leaders debate it should be this next
time you're looking for a leader pick a
woman that's been reflected in our stats
tonight as well and here's Paul Johnson
from The Guardian we sat in the Cabinet
Room together we took decisions together
come
on handcuffs Clegg to the bomb and the
next one we look here at the mirror it's
a Lloyd MD snap verdict Clegg better at
debates than government that's what the
political journalists have to say let's
have a look at what some of the other
people that say Rio Ferdinand former
England footballer is Edie looking at
everyone else the way he's looking at me
here in my kitchen something Kay burly
picked up on and here's Judy Murray Andy
Murray's mum ed Miliband has a rather
impressive stare think I might try and
cultivate one like that for Wimbledon